- But I spent a lot of my
time, last year, in America.
The reason being was that
last winter I turned single.
And I broke up with this really good guy.
I mean, Powell, I say I broke up with him,
actually he broke up with me.
(laughs)
Which again, that's just language.
It doesn't matter, it's
just syntax, structure
it's just English it doesn't
matter what way I say it.
I broke up with him he broke
up with me it doesn't matter.
I say potato, he says "you've
got a really good heart
but your personality is a bit much."
It doesn't matter!
It was very interesting
the things people would say
to me once they realized I was single.
Like one thing, do you guys say this?
People would say "oh I heard
you're back on the market"
you say that here?
You're back on the market, I
heard you're back on the market
back on the market, I
grew up in an agricultural
farming background, no
good cow ever goes back
onto the market.
(laughter)
What a thing to say.
The other thing that people
would say, you'd hear them
say it often would be "do
you think it's because
men are intimidated by funny women?"
Men are intimidated.
(barks)
Intimidated, threatened by funny women.
Do you know what women are intimidated by?
The fact that men can
kill us with their hands.
(laughter)
and that's a fair swap,
isn't it, I mean that's fine.
Of course, and I joke but
in fairness, Powell, I have
no idea what it must be
like from my priviledged
position to be walking
down a lay way at night
potentially after a comedy
gig, and you've had a few beers
and you're very nervous and
you're phone's gone dead.
Why didn't you get an uber
at the time you idiot!
And you're walking down a
lay way and you've got your
keys out, because at
any moment a woman might
jump out of a hedge and tell you a joke.
And you wouldn't know what to do.
She'd be like "pull my
finger" and you'd be like
(yells)
Oh Jesus, you'd have to kill her.
you would have to kill her.
The panic of that.